ragazzi buongiorno ciao a tutti ho la
come potete vedere la mia faccia io non
ho dormito ma non avreste dovuto dormire
nemmeno voi perché oggi verrà a bussare
alle nostre porte ragazzi oggi
finalmente parte il willy o quello che
volevo fare io era trovare un modo
fattibile di poter celebrare questo
momento insieme a chi veramente ne segue
è insieme a chi veramente avrebbe
piaciuto e insieme a chi è veramente
avrebbe apprezzato di condividerlo con
me non so che cosa possa succedere sono
gasato terrorizzato stanco euforico allo
stesso momento
forse così che si muore in età precoce 3
è appurato che la mia famiglia sia
scemano ma perché un megafono perché
abbiamo un megafono ragazzi qualcuno
deve farla stare zitta per quelli a
migliaia ragazzi dobbiamo andare tardi
andiamo
allora cos'è il buio nei guai hanno
un'idea che è venuta a me ha tutto il
mio meraviglioso team ossia invece di
fare cose assurde perché non facciamo la
cosa più semplice il milione e sono
tante persone senza le quali questo
traguardo non sarebbe mai stato
possibile e quindi forza cosa più facile
per ringraziarle e quello proprio di
ringraziarle dal vivo allora la prima
persona da cui andremo si chiama chiara
e abitano posto che si chiama tipo conio
tipo vecchio conio una ballerina che
parla i caraibici salsa bachata merengue
kizomba ed è appena tornata da
un'esibizione che cronin a una cosa che
il forestiere a guglielmo che lo stimo
tantissimo termine youtuber presento il
mondo è colui che segue da più tempo e
più volentieri lo stimo non per quello
che fa
ma per quello che è in tutto e per tutto
ma con mia mamma mi ha detto una cosa
così grazie chiara
sto provando ad abbracciarti anzi a da
per baciarti un coniglietto in casa
chiara stiamo arrivando
[Musica]
mamma
va beh
così paradiso rosa verde o nero nero
oppure nero però non l'ho pure verde
verde questo è il primo fu un tipo così
bella guarda di colore mi ha appena
detto che loro non compro niente a
superman supermercato
[Musica]
rossi tanto per detto no no sentitelo
però adesso vedremo alcuni sono però
vogliamo farci firmare da tutte le
persone che incontriamo la la bandiera o
spiegato abbastanza bene ha chiamate con
mandato la mail ciao maria sì
carissimo e carini
la prima tappa si è conclusa volevamo
rimanere in realtà tutta la vita da
chiara imbarco a mangiare susine
albicocche e accarezzare il dolce
coniglio rem warren brand maremma e
quando dormi appunto fase rem e nemiche
un coniglio che ti per accollare la
notte visto che siamo in zona abbiamo
pensato di prendere pure una piccola
deviazione per andare a salutare un
amico che io conosco in realtà da un bel
po di tempo su internet e finalmente a
battere questa barriera che ci ha
separato
fino ad oggi che era il telefono e la
distanza soprattutto giusto per
salutarla di un abbraccio e poi
proseguire verso andiamo genova la
liguria la liguria e proseguire verso
genova
la liguria linea sei pronto ad andare
certo sono nato pronto di questo sin
dalla gara di danza
ragazzi siamo arrivati a cerreto guidi e
storico tra jacopo meglio e sono un po
emozionato sera nella bandiera era
attaccato la bandiera ragazzi allora la
bandiera giusto non era a vendere giusta
non mi mettono dietro nel qual è la
bandiera giusta nessuno qui capisce
no ragazzi non ho parole enrico che
dimentica il ricco e poi non so se non
ti amo cioè provvidamente ce ne siamo
resi conto chirico oggi è miss maglietta
bagnata in realtà con pure una
bellissima partita cerca l'argine
salve non c è nell ascolto no sei
giovane mancino me sfondi a marradi
panna
noi però quando non indicato zuccherino
almeno posso giocare prima perché no la
fanno sorridere sapere cosa mangia un
bruto cosa mi metto che non può farsi
daniele non sapevo cosa non limitato
niente mandiamo 39 come verona onlus e
la vorrei chiamare qualcosa col treno mi
piacerebbe
sa dire non l'avrete di impatto tipo
vorrebbe dentro non funzionerebbe non
sempre i dolci offerti non scappiamo
prima vicini perse tale tesi
ma se non c'è sotto qualcosa vabbè
rimaste come se ci sta dimenticando
tutto
grazie ciao sono un gel ma siccome se
come pellegrini creda fermarci a cena
sei sicura al cento per cento
ecco
vai piatti rotti possiamo ce ne andiamo
a cena chiara da tutti a cena da chiara
abbiamo pure svoltato la cena di voler o
il tempo e sarò già da terra ragazzi
siamo a uscio in provincia di genova
anche c'è scusate se vi era un po
durante il tragitto volevo dirvi che
quando arriva the house dovete prendere
il primo bivio sulla sinistra ingrosso
sono piazzetta con le parcheggi
taccheggio norme proprie io la amo già
ragazzi che avrebbero parcheggiato
stiamo arrivando stiamo rimandiamo cara
chiara dove sai caro hai detto che
rebellin atti ciao chiara pia chiara era
chiara
[Applauso]
ecco perché oggi ho incontrato solo
chiave come sai dichiara hai detto che
c'erano gatti ma questi casi peggiori
perché con esso
[Musica]
mi ero a casa senza del grida e meno
della gente con la bandiera perciò io
sono al presidente fiero loro marcia con
una bandiera gridando ci sono loro ti
prego che mi darà soddisfazioni gigante
sensi arrivata a casa mi devo far la
doccia gli asciugamani da stenderà e lui
dice ha detto chiaro che arrivano
quattro possibili subito eletto laden o
siamo in quattro c'è anche chiara va
bene non ho altri quattro che pulisce
vale soprattutto l'isip ammesso io vado
a comprare però basta primavera come si
scrive ma viva viva bene la pasta
primavera gli ho detto ma che è la pasta
pizza e gli dissi ma certo se volete
dire una volta al mese
sappiamo
una volta al mese e ha fatto quello che
gianmarco definisce ordini visive che se
tutti una cosa a rischi di prendere il
colera
però io non so se l'abbiamo detto no
però la cosa che c'è più piaciuta
dichiara che ha scritto abito in un
paesino dove ci sono più gatti che
persone ragazzi siamo abbiamo messo
piede o ci fosse stato un miagolio del
gatto la simpatia dei gatti segua una
tela tale idea io la matematica lo sai
cosa vuoi questi un'equazione venire per
vedere lei non è un attrice ma dieci
mesi fa ero al festival della carica
società umbra che ha in testa
sei tu dieci mesi fa erano il festival
della comunicazione è un suo amico viene
da me mi disse fai un videomessaggio a
questa mia amica è vederlo video è
successo dopo
certo è la figlia del vice simile
a giulia carabinieri
[Applauso]
bisogna parlare con le forze dell'ordine
con i ragazzi ho appena visto una
lucciola
anzi una lucciola più bella purtroppo so
bene che scomparsa si è spenta viva e
apritevi vissuto allora lui è che il
ragazzo dichiara di esser scusami oddio
con chi stai
capisco la figlia del vigile nola
allora ragazzi siamo stanchi morti la
prima giornata è finita ci mette a
dormire non c'è più
anzi se vi dico no il giorno dopo e
stiamo andando a pavia
siamo in macchina e stiamo andando a
farci rapinare perché di colpo e buio
tutto quanto ma dove sei
noi siamo ragazzi stava andando a
trovare laura paesino che si chiama
tornio
per ogni brani broni un'azienda vinicola
ed ama la natura va spesso in montagna
per sciare anche nel periodo estivo
mazza figo do sia sul terriccio
devo chiedere a chi non dichiara martina
sentina proverbi avanti noi cosa classi
da qui la russa ristorante di finale
sono martina come si può notare dal nome
fra lo produce tutto ciò che si sa
arrivare la macchina ma diciamo che
mangiamo non per forza polemica perché è
[Applauso]
un ragazzo
a broni abravanel e carina
lavoravo piccola pausa per mangiarsi una
cosa stavo andando da chiara a putin per
poterti dire che mi ha regalato al sacco
dei momenti bellissimi soprattutto con
della triste per per esempio il comune
più persone idee in più perché sarebbero
una passat aspettano spesi per quello
che posso dire video e diciamo che non
mi sono persa uno stand di trap in quel
punto in usa quando mi incontra dal vivo
se ci sarà il lido non so se si
ricorderà di medico sei unico
cioè tu sei iscritto con la prossima
ospite
in realtà è sempre ospite l'artico è
sempre uno spirito l'anno
andiamo andiamo verso forlì
[Musica]
stiamo bene
sai qual è la verità
smettere di guidare per 5 minuti
e guglielmo esatta l'uscita messo di
milano anzi sono la doppia vita di lidia
dinos coperchio via
saluti come sempre ci siamo appena santa
ti dico basta ai una voce pure ragazzi e
michela ci sta portando in un posto dove
c'è praticamente un cartello che dice
vietato l'accesso ai cani anche se al
guinzaglio e che dicono praticamente in
questo qui sia il parco di conigli e che
i coniglietti possono pagare in giro
tranquillamente
dove sono i coniglietti non me ne vado
finché non ero io poi mi apprezzano in
cui la coppa ragazzi cinquina teocoli io
ho buttato con ios
ma non puoi correre ciccone appena
mandata stella enrico col coniglio non
vuole avere a che fare con te marco il
documentario ne ho appena visti 34 st
persone ma è un bidone prezzi e un
quarto pieno di conigli c'è nel senso mi
sembrava chiaro la descrizione che è
stata data che si sono salvati
chi vuol dire attacca nico sono erbivori
ma no ai conigli e non sono animali
anche pericolosi con i velociraptor
forse quelli domestici sono più
pericolosi forse sta per scoppiare una
rissa coniglio contro un rapace la
nutria cento quella che succede così
eccola
un ragazzino mi giocherò in acqua e la
mamma vorrebbe il messaggio altre specie
diverse di animali che riescono a
convivere insieme l'uomo e l'uomo di
tutta la stessa specie non riesce spesso
a farlo infatti se c'è qualcosa di
terribile sappiatelo ok che sono i miei
piani
i miei piedi papa
[Applauso]
grazie
grazie grazie ragazzi e gianmarco e
terrorizzato per i conigli ha paura che
li accettiamo guarda che i duemila hanno
un concetto intellettivo più alto del
giusto allora sono loro che accettano me
stiamo andando arrivi di questa sera
beccheremo un pochino di persone devo
ancora capire come fare ma sono sicuro
che troveremo un modo dobbiamo farcela
ragazzi e solo in secondo il giorno non
possiamo mollare mai
adesso nella farci un giro e vediamo se
c'è qualche persona che abbiamo così ha
raccattato su instagram
fatemi tenderemo a dormire presto
seguirà vuoto
ma scusa per casa profondo lavoro ce
l'ha il canale ma mai
guglielmo non vuole salire
ormai io lo metto questo nel di roma
non voglio 700 puntare a fare un
sondaggio ma invero lasciate un commento
facciamolo sapere ci tornerò e lo farò
ma siamo in periferia
no siamo sul lungomare dire che diviso
per rivas giocatore arriva mamma
adesso vorrei da tutti una cosa un po
più
per fare
girate se appena tornata in albergo
siamo fuori con torniamo per strada sono
dei 213 stiamo morendo di sonno ci
vediamo veramente fra due secondi giorno
numero 3 ci dirigiamo verso l'umbria si
viaggia veloci sulla paura
no no
in realtà grazie
cosa ci dicono a cannes e quindi rimani
a perugia magna la cioccolata gli
spiriti degli amanti preferiscono
indugiare tra i sogni sono più concreti
un giorno tu con tenerezza amato punto
la nostra d'oro adesso ragionato e
adesso ad ora siamo ne ha bisogno di
ozio inquietante smetti di mangiarci ma
sai che comunque si vede la differenza
siccome fi video ad esse come mi facevi
prima si perché si vede che sei più uno
stanzino
c'è poi conto che io ho sempre di attori
non conosco guglielmo scilla conosco qui
il guscio perché era il personaggio che
si è ricreato steel interna invece
adesso ovvio non è che conosciamo il 100
per cento certo però conosciamo più buia
muscillo adesso quello che percepisco
versatevi un leggero velo davanti cero
velo da santa maria degli angeli è tutto
a questo punto noi passiamo per magia in
realtà davanti a questa bellissima
chiesa
sì non so perché non l'abbia vista prima
credo che sia la chiesa di santa
marie saint anne marie angelorum importi
non so leggerlo il latino
si no
ciao ciao massimiliano se vengono qua mi
faccio esplori questi tra l'altro una
challenge per voi mi dovete guardare il
primo che arriva da per serico
concentrazione concentrazione l'angolo
rosso e non primo aspetto vince il primo
biglietto o non rido ma qui ci sono le
cascate delle cascate delle sono le
cascate più alte del dell'europa io
facevo venire con lui regalo non ci
siamo mai venuti ucciderà sarà
dimenticato
[Risate]
a bagnarsi in carenza
saia prezzo nei pressi di una cascata
[Musica]
ansa
t
[Musica]
siamo appena rete l'aquila vi chiedo
scusa se sono un po rallentato di giro
che non sta dormendo adesso prendiamo
mangiarci arrosticini vi prego c'è una
voglia di arrosticini che mi si porta
via
[Musica]
in realtà mi dispiace un sacco non
riuscire a visitare tutte quante le
famiglie o magari dei ragazzi vittime
del sisma che c'è stata in passato cioè
non che non ci abbia provato ci ho
provato a contattare varie diverse e
svariate associazioni non c'è purtroppo
risposta nessuno quindi diciamo che è
l'unico che se possiamo fare più
camminare guardare quello che che c'è
quello che il terremoto ha lasciato
senza una guida e questa cosa un pochino
ci dispiace
ciao e auguri a te 4
noi siamo guidati scorso
nessuno di quanti grazie soprattutto per
i cani in qualche modo perfetto per
dirci addio concreto
addio
oggi soprattutto le due ragazze ne
stiamo scappando
c'era
scusate abbandonato il posto di lavoro
ma non facciamo arrivato ciao ciao
siete come dei furbi che parlano invece
che cosa fate sentire questo studente
[Risate]
allora stai cambierò son finiti
biodinamica delle tesi di ingegneria
medicina santa tecla tienimi design e
con e attesi a torino vero
che cosa ci manca primo decennale a suo
tempo l'ho fatta sul la differenza delle
persone che si portano i sogni o meno
perché c'è chi ricorda che più sogni
stato bene detto ridendo
fatene una con l'indice destro in su a
chi li prende male per l'attesa scusate
ma poco tempo
ciao ragazzi sono appena arrivati in
albergo volevo solamente dire una cosa
perché stasera no proprio riempito il
cuore c'è luigi amore ti posso dormire
fra i due secondi fra due secondi per
favore di quello che volevo dire io è
che bellissimo poter ricambiare
l'affetto che ti viene dato perché ora
ricevo tantissimo e stasera ieri sera il
primo giorno è stata una roba
incredibile e mi sento veramente
fortunato
detto ciò facciamo una velocissima
precisione a domani ok siamo in molise a
venafro e stavo per andare incontrare
una ragazza che purtroppo ci ha chiesto
di non portare le videocamere
all'interno della sua abitazione perché
non vogliono quindi fondamentalmente
quello che faremo è un giro attorno per
dimostrare che il molise esiste questo è
un piccolo arbusto del molise questa
invece è una ringhiera del molise
e questo accada del molise di
spegnimento intellettuale
vengono disabili
vero
guarda io so chiuso l'occhio per minuti
pericolo
dove stiamo andando
direzione gifuni 22 anni fa l'ideale
[Applauso]
ho messo qui mi lanciava delle cannonate
abbattere parate mi sa come fare
i numeri che non era abituato visto
cucchietti contro loro due
eravamo 5 non a sparare sulla croce
rossa
[Applauso]
ragazzi siamo un pochino stanchi o
fondamentalmente è la prima volta dopo
quattro giorni che facciamo veramente un
pasto dall'inizio alla fine mangiato
tutto quanto e quindi non abbiamo
ripreso nulla perché avevamo fame come
disse il baggio è arrivato adesso il
momento di tarcento notte perché
ho appena finito il turno
e ovvio
quindi abbiamo
e quinto di qualche giorno
milioni quinto giorno siamo a salerno
faremo un giro qui in zona perché c'è
una ragazza che vorremmo trovare poi ci
spostiamo da tutt'altra parte perché è
arrivato il momento della puglia andiamo
da maria de nozza ecco me non ce la fa
uscire guarda alla mancata
grazie ragazzi questa cosa qui è
tipicissima tutti cioè proprio anzi con
un certa delle bio pubblicista santino
padre pio
sì perché stanno scendendo
una cosa visto che il magistrato anni fa
precisa riuscita l'altro giorno il nord
su facebook no e quindi senso ma tu
immaginati che culo che una volta del
cerchio se giovani che lo trovo a casa
io ho mandato il form dicendo la mia
fidanzata
fai una cosa mangiano anche tu che
massimo ha pure giocato che la regione
non piacevo la mamma aspettati passa una
persona aspetta un attimo antonella
antonella pronto giorgia c'è tua mamma
che sta tornando a casa che così la
conosciamo
giulia george e sirsi mia uscito solo
pezzo che vuoi non me lo dici
innanzitutto lui terrificante
ammazza che riesci dell'inganno della
morte guarda di one day o riproponiamo
quella foto ad appoggiare la tosse tipo
non so perché una scoliosi avervi qui
una traversata campa quindi cosa vi così
la ritengono tuttavia bravo sta facendo
troppo ridere
nove anni dopo si può vincere questo lo
zuccotto che cosa qui cotto maternal and
me armonie del cioccolato che non so ki
moon
[Risate]
come vedete come
[Musica]
abbiamo appena lasciato il silia e
abbiamo offerto instagram è che un botto
di persone sono venute nel posto in cui
abbiamo coperto praticamente questo
segmento di giornata e quindi abbiamo
deciso di fare un salto al volo a mare
bellissimo ci lanciamo saluti pienamente
poi andiamo verso bari
grazie ciao ora qui sta un po facendo il
cose ma lui
su
allora ti ricordi il video dei macarons
la bellissima ho pianto quando hai
pubblicato il video del pesce d'aprile
chiuso il canale di aver chiuso il
canale vorrei ringraziarti per le risate
ma soprattutto per gli insegnamenti
dovete venire a trovarmi perché voglio
un po di famiglia scena nella mia demo
enrico però perché la mia ragazza è
persa di lui e potrebbe rubarmela fuori
giovane ragazza
enrico è un cassonetto
[Musica]
arriva con il tuo nome e donato 6 stato
selezionato grazie ciao
siamo arrivati a casa di dorato giusto
due persone siamo trovati a tutti che
sei finito e ridevo di questa cosa
esco del tour ma lavorano e mail timoni
il bus e io ritrova quale furono sinuosi
e divertito perché lo sono davvero
dicendo a tutti
mi fermo rispondo dopo 1 ora
mi telefonò numero sconosciuto era tipo
hakim dalla vodafone albania un altro
per prendermi male mi sono arrivati sms
cosicché non succedevano da maicon
numeri strani che io ho nicotra iran il
terrore che foste voi risveglio voi a
dormire giustamente il mio tipo sveglio
dalle 6 mb così così con il ticca le
storie quando però visto il numero non
ho pensato fosse gori pronto si gioca a
dio per bertone di nuove ma se dovrà
essere qui a prescindere poi ha preso
impegni le continua a dire ma guardate
in quella settimana wilbur shaw nel
milione verrà sicuramente l grazie
mattina io con gliel'ho detto lei
disperata e io faccio a tema scusa ti
faccio salutare arriva trovare pure
quelli che facevano tu non capisci cosa
non capisco e le regole ma la storia
lista grande nemico adesso in avanti ad
enrico maida pietro andare a far liti e
le camminava a un certo punto si blocca
io tipo ho matrice velenoso il louvre e
lei no pausa era nessuna storia è
innamoratissima lei si chiama sarà di
saltare per favore cioè minaccia ciao
sarà non vuoi raccontare della nostra
relazione
se sbagli mettiamo insieme ma con la
guarda dentro beckett una vita non fosse
adatto ci sono questo chi è parlerà
c'entra niente è troppo bello per cui
quindi avevamo queste paure e poi data
tipo visto il tuo cliente
noi diciamo 6 si apparto prima volta e
ci siamo innamorati di te ora ogni volta
che pubblici una storia noi se lativo
mandiamo su whatsapp per gridare il top
nel fatto che riunisce un angelo che sia
bello mi è sembrato non facciamo diciamo
hai fatto cambiare idea ciò che impatto
nodi che seppe usciti da casa di donato
adesso direzione bari non so nemmeno
cosa sta facendo sono
dai facciamo caiano io non ho voce in
capitolo
saia non è partito in un ampio capitolo
come farà a sopravvivere una statua
[Applauso]
è il coperto in importa qui scotti lo so
sarebbe stato meglio se fosse stato vero
marco berry in quella miglia sono sempre
superamento cela una per l'amica conosca
meglio
no
rosa per me a favore
ragazzi grazie ancora in bocca al lupo
per tutto
il debutto nel culo 76 anni prendendo
che cosa facciate ma so che avete
contribuito da da bagnato
ragazzi siamo alla tana del polpo e per
questo panino
il colpo è la fine del mondo
un colpo al cuore mai mangiare una cosa
così buona dopo questo saremo già
[Musica]
gianni amore fire